en quelques heures des files de voitures
rapplique de toute la france près de 150
hommes issus de la communauté tchétchène
pendant plusieurs heures ce dimanche ils
menacent et occupent le quartier des
grésillés à dijon
d'où vient-il comment se sont ils
mobilisés aussi rapidement dans la
diaspora tchétchène
il ya un levier très puissant c'est le
collectif le village la famille voir le
clan qu'on appelle le type si un membre
de la communauté a commis quelque chose
de mal soit du légal soit un correct
soit contrevenant aux règles l'ensemble
du collectif va se sentir entachée et
qui est un membre du collectif hype et
offensé long l'ensemble du collectif du
clan de la famille va se sentir une
responsabilité de réactions de soutien
de solidarité
que sont ils venus dire que venait-il
exprimé au juste on compte environ 150
milles tchétchènes en europe un peu
moins de la moitié se trouve en france
une diaspora nourrit depuis 25 ans par
deux conflits séparatistes avec la
russie cette société a été laminé par
les deux guerres elle a été très animée
et psychologiquement socialement et donc
il ya quelque chose si sans doute qui se
joue là dans cette espèce de
déménagement là d'une espèce de coup
d'éclat ou de performances guerrière
comme ça en pleine ville avec aussi la
convocation des éléments identitaires
simple démonstration de force alors pour
dire son appartenance au peuple
tchétchène
mais justement qu'en pense le reste de
la communauté sur les réseaux sociaux
est allé tchétchènes qui désapprouve ce
qui se passe il ya des tchétchènes qui
l'assument et le revendique en
expliquant qu'il s'agit d'une défense
c'est à dire que nous tchétchène nous
vivons en france 2 nous respectons la
loi la constitution l'état de droit edd
ça mais il faut pas venir nous chercher
un constat confirmé dimanche soir par
l'un d'entre eux française
elle n'oublie pas de tirer sur des gens
non ce n'est pas la pauvre tuer des gens
ça ne fait pas plus à recourir à gauche
à droite mais pour défendre nos valeurs
on est prêt à faire ça tout récemment
des scènes similaires ont été observées
à nice à toulouse ou dans l'aube mais l'
enquête ne fait pas encore de lien entre
ces événements